- [Instructor] We have
so far spent many videos
talking about the ideal gas law,
that pressure times volume is equal
to the number of moles
times the ideal gas constant
times temperature measured in kelvin.
What we're going to do in this video
is attempt to modify the ideal gas law
to try to take into account
when we're dealing with real gases,
gases where the volume
of the actual particles
are worth considering,
that we don't just say
they're negligible compared to
the volume of the container.
And intermolecular forces are something
that we would like to
take into consideration.
So let's think about how
we could modify this.
And to help us a little bit,
I'm just gonna solve for P.
So I'm gonna divide both sides by volume,
so we can say pressure is
equal to number of moles
times ideal gas constant
times temperature measured
in kelvin divided by volume.
So first, how would we adjust this
if we want to take into
account the actual volume
in which the molecules can move around?
Well, if we wanted to do that,
we would replace this
volume right over here
with this volume minus the
volume of the actual particles.
So what's the volume of the
actual particles going to be?
Well, it's going to be
the number of particles
times some constant,
based on how large each
of those particles are,
maybe on average.
And let's just call that b.
So we could view this as a
modified ideal gas law equation,
we're now all of a sudden,
we are taking into account
the fact that these particles
have some real volume to them,
but of course we also
know it's not just about
the volume of the particles,
we also need to adjust
for the intermolecular
forces between the particles.
And we know that in many cases
those intermolecular forces
are attractive forces,
and so they would take
away from the pressure.
And so we need some term
that accounts for that,
a term that accounts for
taking away the pressure
due to intermolecular forces.
So term for intermolecular forces.
Now I know what some
of y'all are thinking.
"Do we always subtract?
Might not there be some situations
in which we actually have
repulsive forces between particles
and it would actually
add to the pressure?"
And there could be scenarios like that.
You could imagine if they all
have a strong negative charge,
they wanna get away from each
other as far as they can.
And that could actually
add to the pressure,
but in that situation, we
could subtract a negative
and then that would be additive.
Now, how could we take
this into consideration?
So we know from Coulomb's
law that the force
between two particles,
two charged particles
is going to be proportional
to the charge on one
particle times the charge
on the other particle divided
by the distance squared.
Now, obviously if we're
dealing with a lot of particles
in a container, we're not
gonna be able to think
about the forces for
between any two particles.
But one way to think about it is
in terms of how concentrated
are the particles generally.
So when we're trying to think of a term
that takes into account
the intermolecular forces
or how much we're reducing the pressure
because of those intermolecular forces,
maybe that can be proportional
to not just the concentration
of the particles, and that'd
be the number of particles
divided by the volume,
but that times itself,
because we're talking
about the interaction
between two particles at a time,
very similar to what we
see in Coulomb's law,
because the end of the day
these really are just Coulomb forces.
So this thing right over
here is gonna be proportional
to the concentration times itself.
Or we could maybe call this some constant,
for the proportionality,
times n over v squared,
where a would depend on
the attractive forces
between gas particles.
And what we have just constructed,
and let me rewrite it again,
this ideal gas equation,
and actually let me put this orange term
back on the left hand side.
So if I write it this
way, that pressure plus a
times n over v squared is equal to n R T
over the volume of our container
minus the number of molecules we have
times some constant b, based
on how large on average
those molecules or those particles are.
This right over here is a
pretty good competence equation
for when we're dealing
with more real gases,
ones that have intermolecular forces,
and one where the actual
particles have volume.
And this actually does a pretty good job,
and there's a name for it,
it's called the Van der Waals equation.
And there's many different
ways you might see it,
you could see it written like this,
or we could try to take this blue part
and get it on the left hand side
so it really looks like
what we saw at the top.
Where there it would be
written as, and I'll write it,
actually write it this way.
Pressure plus some constant
times the density squared,
let me close that parentheses,
times the volume minus
the number of molecules
times some constant is
going to be equal n R T,
is going to be equal to n R T.
And all of this looks really complicated,
but the end of the day it
is just our ideal gas law
modified for intermolecular forces
and the actual volume of the particles.